Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“Race to Recurring Revenue”挑战。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. What is the role for psychology in catastrophic injury cases and what is case
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士一对一的辅导机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。心理学在灾难性伤害案件中扮演什么角色？什么是案例
management and how can that play out as a psychologist? That is what we are going to be exploring in today's episode as we meet a qualified clinical psychologist who specialises in all of this. There's so much to learn about compassion, dignity, respect and doing a job well. I hope you will find this so useful. Welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. One of my favourite things about psychology is just how people can take essentially the same qualification and turn it into something completely new and unique from what another qualified professional might be doing. That is exactly what is going to be happening today.
管理？作为一名心理学家，这又意味着什么？这就是我们今天要在节目中探讨的内容，我们将采访一位专门从事这些工作的合格临床心理学家。关于同情心、尊严、尊重以及如何做好一份工作，有很多值得学习的地方。希望你会觉得这期节目非常有用。欢迎来到《Aspiring Psychologist》播客。我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。心理学最让我着迷的一点是，人们可以拿着本质上相同的资格证书，将其转化为与同行完全不同且独特的职业路径。这正是我们今天要探讨的内容。
We're going to be meeting someone with the same professional qualification as me, which is clinical psychologist, and we're going to be seeing about the work that she does and how she does it and why it lights her up. I hope you find it so useful and I'll look forward to catching you on the other side. Hi Shabnam, welcome along to the podcast. Thank you for having me, It's exciting to be here. So you are a qualified clinical psychologist, aren't you? I am, yes. So I qualified in 2008, which makes me feel incredibly old. But I like to think of myself as wise and experienced now. So yes, yes, I've been qualified for a little while. Brilliant. Could you tell us a little bit about your journey to psychology?
我们将采访一位和我拥有相同专业资格——临床心理学家——的嘉宾，了解她的工作内容、工作方式以及她为何对这份工作充满热情。希望你觉得这期节目很有用，我们稍后见。你好Shabnam，欢迎来到播客。谢谢你的邀请，很高兴能来到这里。所以你是一位合格的临床心理学家，对吧？是的，没错。我是2008年获得资格的，这让我觉得自己老了很多。但我现在更愿意把自己看作是睿智且经验丰富的。所以，是的，我已经从业一段时间了。太棒了。你能给我们讲讲你的心理学之路吗？
So I recognised that psychology was something you can actually make a job out of when I was at school, aspiring to be a medical student, actually, and to be a doctor. That was kind of my ambition at the time. And I realised quite soon into my A-levels that I'm not going to get there. I'm not a straight A student. And also, I really don't understand chemistry and biology like I probably should if I'm going to be a medic and then I started thinking about and I didn't realize this is the first foray I suppose into understanding values and the importance of values started thinking about you know what do I actually like doing what what interests me what gets me going and I came to a bit of a dead end until at school someone came and spoke to me um to speak to the school about um sort of like in a motivational interviewing kind of way sort of motivational
我在学校时意识到心理学可以成为一份职业，当时我其实立志成为一名医学生，想当医生。那是当时我的抱负。但在A-level课程开始不久后，我就意识到我可能做不到。我不是那种门门拿A的学生。而且，如果我要当医生，我真的不像我应该做到的那样理解化学和生物。于是我开始思考——我没意识到这是我第一次尝试理解价值观及其重要性——我开始思考，我到底喜欢做什么？什么让我感兴趣？什么能驱动我？我一度陷入了死胡同，直到学校里有人来和我们谈话，嗯，以一种激励访谈的方式，就像一位励志
speaker and I just thought wow to use words so powerfully to change how people feel is an incredible um position to be in and how you can use that for good. And I don't need anything. I just need my words. And so that's kind of where the psychology came from, the idea of doing psychology. So my first introduction into psychology was actually at university. And that's where I learned about clinical psychology. And my journey to clinical psychology was actually via a PhD. And then I became, yeah, I got into clinical psychology training and here I am doing two different things, but using very much psychology skills nonetheless. Thank you for that whistle-stop tour.
演讲者。我当时想，哇，用语言如此有力地改变人们的感受，这真是一个了不起的职位，而且你可以用它来行善。我不需要任何东西，我只需要我的语言。这就是心理学的由来，做心理学的想法。所以我对心理学的第一次接触其实是在大学。也就是在那里，我了解到了临床心理学。我通往临床心理学的道路其实是通过博士学位。然后我，是的，我进入了临床心理学培训，现在我在这里做着两件不同的事情，但依然运用着心理学的技能。谢谢你的简要介绍。
So you are Dr. Dr. Shabnamberi Khan. I am, it seems. Or Dr. Square, as my friend calls me sometimes. You must have been a really good support to your cohort as well in terms of your academic rigor and your research skills too. I know that I would have loved to have had somebody in that regard on our cohort too. Yeah, it was, um it was it is a really good set of skills to have I don't necessarily think you need to do a PhD to have the you know to develop an interest and a passion for research but I think that has carried through um certainly that sort of background for sure so yeah it's um it's a good it's a good set of skills for sure certainly is right so let's have a think then without obviously giving away any client case
所以你是Shabnam Beri Khan博士。是的，看来是这样。或者像我朋友有时叫我的那样，“博士平方”。你在学术严谨性和研究技能方面一定也为你的同学提供了很好的支持。我知道如果我们的同学里有这样的人，我也会很高兴的。是的，这确实是一套非常好的技能。我不认为你一定要读博士才能培养出对研究的兴趣和热情，但我认为这种背景确实一直伴随着我，所以是的，这确实是一套很好的技能。确实如此。好了，让我们来思考一下，在不泄露任何客户案例的前提下，
studies because that wouldn't be appropriate but could you give us a couple of examples about what serious and catastrophic injury looks like because that's the area that you're working in at the moment yes that's right so I work both as a treating psychologist in the serious and catastrophic injury field and a case manager in the same field so it's sort of two ways into the same client group um but um in terms of if I can give you a sort of a picture of the kind of work that we do do, and then hopefully that will bring, you know, a sort of helpful case study to mind. So the work is very systemic. It's ultimately so when we're thinking either about case management or treating psychology, you are working with people who have suffered a life changing injury. So that means that they are not living the life they would have had had it not been for the injury. And therefore,
因为那样做是不合适的，你能举几个例子说明什么是严重和灾难性伤害吗？因为这是你目前工作的领域。是的，没错。我既担任严重和灾难性伤害领域的治疗心理学家，也担任同一领域的案例经理。所以这是进入同一客户群体的两种方式。但是，如果我能为你描绘一下我们所做工作的画面，希望这能让你想到一个有用的案例研究。这项工作是非常系统化的。归根结底，当我们考虑案例管理或治疗心理学时，你是在与遭受了改变人生伤害的人一起工作。这意味着他们无法过上如果没有受伤本可以拥有的生活。因此，
in order to rehabilitate or to try and achieve their life goals, which they should absolutely be supported to try and achieve, there's an awful lot of systemic input that needs to go in. So I'm talking about therapies, of course, care. In my field, because they are seriously and catastrophically injured, often liable to someone else's mistake, there is a whole legal machine going on around them. So there's a lot of there are a lot of people involved in trying to get someone to live the life they should have been living. And so as a case manager, you're managing that entire package. And there's a lot of formulation work that goes into kind of um pulling all of that together as you can imagine
为了康复或尝试实现他们的人生目标——他们绝对应该得到支持去实现这些目标——需要大量的系统性投入。我指的是治疗、护理等等。在我的领域，因为他们遭受了严重和灾难性的伤害，通常是由于他人的过失，他们周围有一整套法律机制在运作。所以有很多人参与其中，试图让某人过上他们本应过的生活。作为一名案例经理，你要管理整个方案。正如你可以想象的那样，需要进行大量的构思工作来将所有这些整合在一起。
anyone who's kind of trained in or interested in systemic working there's a lot of um interpersonal dynamic uh features that that you draw upon and kind of pulling that story together having a narrative that everyone's working towards is super important um in my opinion um and as a treating psychologist you are then one of the team members so you would be the treating psychologist supporting again usually the system as opposed to specifically the client although there are obviously occasions where you are supporting the clients themselves if they have the capacity and the goals and the outcomes are related to specific work, you know, that they are, that we're working on together.
任何受过系统性工作培训或对此感兴趣的人，都会运用到很多的人际动态特征，将那个故事整合在一起，拥有一个每个人都朝着努力的目标叙事是非常重要的。在我看来，作为一名治疗心理学家，你就是团队成员之一。你通常是支持整个系统，而不是专门针对客户，尽管当然也有一些场合，如果客户有能力，且目标和结果与我们共同努力的具体工作相关，你也会支持客户本人。
So I guess I'm thinking if we work and we do work across the lifespan as well, but you can, as you imagine, the systemic focus is different when you're working with paediatric clients. There is a lot of interagency working schools, sort of any community type input, statutory services, of course. Obviously, you've got the family who are in a very different position working with a child client than the family working, you know, when we're working with an adult client. So there's already, I hope that picture kind of suggests that your lens is quite broad. While you have the potential depth to work with a client who perhaps is struggling with the injury that's happened to them, that may not always be the case. So the work that you do is often very systemic and very trauma, needing to be trauma informed as well. In terms of a case specifically, a good example perhaps of a case could be a particular client.
所以我在想，我们确实跨越整个生命周期工作，但正如你所想象的，当你与儿科客户工作时，系统性的重点是不同的。有很多跨机构的工作，学校，任何社区类型的投入，当然还有法定服务。显然，与处理成人客户的家庭相比，处理儿童客户的家庭处于非常不同的位置。所以我希望这幅图景能表明你的视角相当广阔。虽然你有潜力深入研究那些可能正在为所受伤害而挣扎的客户，但这并不总是情况。所以你所做的工作通常是非常系统化的，也需要具备创伤知情。具体到一个案例，一个好的例子可能是一个特定的客户。
So it's a case managed case that I work with. And one of our treating psychologists is the psychologist on the team as well. And the referral for psychology came through because the the clients, the client was experiencing was exhibiting behaviours of challenge. But in order to understand how how to to think about the function of that behaviour and the communications around it, there was a lot of interdisciplinary working with the speech and language therapist for example um there was um communications with the care team who through that discovery we worked through those interactions we worked out that the care team actually didn't have a lot of brain injury experience um and this client was unfortunately did have a brain injury as a result of the accident that happened and the what was happening was that the staff retention was very poor as a result
这是一个我参与的案例管理案例。我们的一位治疗心理学家也是团队中的心理学家。心理学转诊是因为客户表现出了挑战性行为。但为了理解如何思考该行为的功能及其背后的沟通，我们与言语和语言治疗师进行了大量的跨学科合作。例如，我们与护理团队进行了沟通，通过发现我们了解到护理团队实际上并没有太多的脑损伤经验。不幸的是，这位客户确实因为发生的事故而患有脑损伤，发生的情况是员工流失率非常高。
and so the psychologist and me as a gaze manager we were working in unison to try and understand how to create a stable team before we can even think about what the behaviors are about specifically because the system wasn't quite right we had to get mum and dad on board with that and so there was lots of joint working and lots of thinking around how they were relating to what had happened to their family member. We also had to check in a lot, a number of times with capacity. So the client, as I'm sure a lot of your audience will know, that capacity is time specific and decision specific. So we had to really bring that into how we were thinking around the client's needs, linking in obviously with the legal team who wanted to understand
所以心理学家和我作为案例经理，我们齐心协力试图在考虑行为的具体含义之前，先建立一个稳定的团队。因为系统不太对劲，我们必须让父母双方都参与进来，所以有很多联合工作，也有很多关于他们如何看待家庭成员所发生事情的思考。我们还必须多次检查行为能力。客户，我相信你们很多听众都知道，行为能力是针对特定时间和特定决策的。所以我们必须真正将其纳入我们对客户需求的思考中，显然要与法律团队联系，他们想了解
what we were doing and why we were doing it, as well as thinking with the rest of the sort of therapy team so they understood how we were making sense of the behaviours, but needing to do this sort of pre-emptive piece around stabilising the system in which the client was operating. It got really complicated at one point, but between sort of the psychologist having a really strong formulation that everyone bought into, and from which there was a sort of shared understanding of what the goals are that were based on what the client was wanting we were able to well we still are navigating through how to work in unison and with the client rather than to the client and so it's been a really long piece of work. I think that one of the biggest differences of working in our field is that there's a lot more liaison, particularly with the legal teams, because they're the ones who are collating all of this data that you're otherwise generating and having to justify it, either from a cost perspective or in terms of what usually in a cost perspective, but in terms of clinical advantage,
我们在做什么以及为什么要这样做，同时也要与治疗团队的其他成员一起思考，以便他们理解我们是如何解读这些行为的。但我们需要在稳定客户所处的系统方面做这种先发制人的工作。有一次情况变得非常复杂，但在心理学家拥有每个人都认同的强有力的构思，并从中对基于客户意愿的目标达成共识之后，我们能够——好吧，我们仍在探索如何齐心协力，与客户一起工作，而不是对客户进行工作。所以这是一项非常漫长的工作。我认为我们领域工作最大的区别之一是，有更多的联络工作，特别是与法律团队，因为他们是整理所有这些数据的人，而你必须证明其合理性，无论是从成本角度，还是从临床优势的角度。
like why would you spend that time thinking about stabilising the care team? And so you end up being quite analytical in a different way to perhaps if you were working purely clinically with a client. Does that make sense? Yeah, it does. It's a very big job, isn't it? And one with many different plates spinning simultaneously I think but um you know I think what we're talking about here is like big big accidents at work big accidents in education settings basically anything that's not your fault that might be like a serious acquired brain injury or maybe even you know someone having to be a wheelchair
比如，你为什么要花时间考虑稳定护理团队？所以你最终会以一种与纯粹临床工作不同的方式进行分析。这有道理吗？是的，很有道理。这是一份非常大的工作，不是吗？而且我认为同时要处理很多不同的事情。但你知道，我认为我们在这里谈论的是工作中的重大事故、教育环境中的重大事故，基本上任何不是你的错，可能导致严重的后天性脑损伤，或者可能是某人必须终身坐轮椅，
user for life and or both that's kind of the level we're we're talking about here is it Shabnam? Absolutely often our clients are injured as a result of medical negligence and so we get a lot of birth injuries for example or um clinical negligence um you know procedure going wrong and leaving someone either as you say with spinal cord injury orthopedic injuries or a brain injury is is big sadly um and it could or it could be a road traffic accident that's our usual sort of um uh sort of incident sort of uh you know categories you could say you're right things happen at work things happen in other localities as well um uh settings so it's it's um injuries can happen anywhere it's more prolific i think than we perhaps might otherwise imagine yeah yeah thank you and how do you keep so positive and hopeful for what
或者两者兼有。这就是我们在这里谈论的程度，是吗，Shabnam？绝对是。我们的客户通常是由于医疗过失而受伤，所以我们有很多出生损伤的例子，或者临床过失，你知道，程序出错，导致某人像你所说的那样，患有脊髓损伤、骨科损伤或脑损伤，这很严重，很遗憾。或者可能是道路交通事故，这是我们通常的事故类别。你说得对，事情发生在工作中，也发生在其他地方，所以伤害可能发生在任何地方。我认为这比我们想象的要普遍得多。是的，是的，谢谢你。你是如何保持如此积极和充满希望的，面对
might sometimes feel like a really really emotive challenging role that you're doing I think I suppose it comes back to that values piece right at the beginning really knowing what interests me and how I can make that um operational in my life um and it's taken me a really long time to get there because I didn't quite realize that was actually on the right lines way back when um and then you get distracted don't you and then suddenly you're in that um place of needing where it matters because actually the clashes and the conflicts become more apparent the you know the more you live life I suppose and then other priorities kick in family and you know just wanting to be me turns out that that's quite important and I needed to build time in so I think there are several transitions that happen.
有时感觉非常情绪化、充满挑战的角色？我想这归根结底还是回到最初的价值观问题，真正了解什么让我感兴趣，以及我如何能在生活中将其付诸实践。这花了我很长时间才做到，因为我当时并没有完全意识到我走在正确的轨道上。然后你会分心，不是吗？然后突然间你处于那个需要的地方，因为实际上，你生活得越久，冲突和矛盾就越明显。然后其他优先事项就会出现，家庭，你知道，只是想做回自己，事实证明这非常重要，我需要留出时间。所以我认为发生了几次转变。
So it's not just the mindset side of things. It was also kind of where I was working and how I wanted to work and where would I get that best work life balance? And I think for me, I realised there was a gap in the market, so to speak, in terms of psychology, supporting these catastrophically injured clients and thinking, why is there a gap in the market? This is outrageous. But I was working as a case manager at the time, so it was my way in. But I kind of smelt what sold, so to speak, to use an Alan Sugar term. And it was quite clear that this service was not available either in the NHS in that long term way. And it wasn't otherwise seemingly obviously available in the private sector. And so that positivity comes from, I think, wanting good things for our clients but in the process of that and giving things to our clients that
所以这不仅仅是心态方面的问题。这也关乎我在哪里工作，我想如何工作，以及我在哪里能获得最好的工作与生活平衡？对我来说，我意识到心理学在支持这些灾难性伤害客户方面存在市场空白，我想，为什么会有市场空白？这太离谱了。但我当时是作为案例经理工作的，所以这是我的切入点。但我有点闻到了商机，用Alan Sugar的话说。很明显，这种服务在NHS中没有那种长期的提供方式。而且在私营部门似乎也不明显。所以这种积极性来自于，我认为，想要为我们的客户带来好的结果，但在为客户提供他们需要的东西和他们周围系统所需的东西的过程中，
they need and and the systems around them but also being able to you know kind of have something that's reasonable for me as well to be able to stay myself in but I don't know am I really answering your question yeah I don't know no absolutely you are and you know I think you're also illuminating some people say if you can't see it you can't be it but you're actually reckoning you're saying well I can see I can't see it so I can be it and you've kind of given yourself permission to go out there and and create that unique service for that niche that was already there that nobody really noticed was there yeah I think um it yeah it was a it absolutely and I think um when you when you are in touch with that passion and when you are in touch with that um desire to help which is obviously why we do what we do ultimately I think
也能让自己保持合理的状态。但我不知道，我真的回答你的问题了吗？是的，绝对回答了。而且我认为你也在启发一些人。有人说“如果你看不见，你就做不到”，但你实际上是在说“我能看见，我看不见它，所以我可以创造它”。你给了自己许可去走出去，为那个已经存在但没人注意到的利基市场创造那种独特的服务。是的，我认为，当你有那种激情，当你拥有那种想要帮助他人的愿望时，这显然是我们做这份工作的最终原因，我认为
it it was it was obviously a bit easier because I sort of fell into the case management world and then realized gosh there's this area that I can really help with. And I suppose it took courage to be able to do that as well. But I think, I think, yeah, it's, and it's really challenged me in terms of kind of thinking outside of what I've been trained to do and thinking oh I've got to think about other things like KPIs and you know how do I be the how can I run some how can I create something that also doesn't lose me in it but how do I get others to sort of how can I use the resources that are out there in the world to be able to help so it you know where I didn't think I was a creative person I'm actually creative in this way I think you know don't give me you know any drawing material because I will not draw anything for you that's you know resembles anything that I say I'm drawing
这显然容易了一些，因为我进入了案例管理世界，然后意识到，天哪，有这样一个领域我可以真正提供帮助。我想这确实需要勇气。但我认为，这确实挑战了我，让我跳出我所受的训练去思考，我想“我必须考虑其他事情，比如KPI，我该如何经营，我该如何创造一些东西，同时又不迷失其中，但我该如何让其他人……我该如何利用世界上现有的资源来提供帮助？”所以，你知道，我以前不认为自己是一个有创造力的人，但我实际上是以这种方式有创造力的。我想，你知道，不要给我任何绘画材料，因为我画不出任何像样的东西。
but you know it the creative element in me comes out I think here when we're talking about how to create something to offer people that they wouldn't otherwise get perhaps um and yeah that that's massively motivating for me oh absolutely yeah and I also don't think I'm particularly creative but there are many many things I do create and um for listeners of the podcast they will have um probably maybe already listened to an episode which as we record is coming out imminently but isn't currently available right now but it's with Juliette Dr Juliette who is creative clinical psychologist over on Instagram and she's wonderfully creative I don't know if you've seen her drawings but she's they're so good they're so good you should
但你知道，当我们谈论如何创造一些东西来提供给人们，而他们本来可能得不到时，我内在的创造性元素就显现出来了。是的，这对我来说是非常大的动力。哦，绝对是的。而且我也不认为自己特别有创造力，但我确实创造了很多很多东西。对于播客的听众来说，他们可能已经听过一期节目了，在我们录制时这期节目即将发布，但目前还不可用。那是关于Juliette博士的，她是Instagram上的一位创意临床心理学家，她非常有创造力。我不知道你有没有看过她的画，但它们太棒了，太棒了，你应该
check them out I'll send you a link um she's so good and the way that she kind of depicts clients experiences um so she's currently working um with services with children and um asylum seekers and the way that she kind of weaves that into her work but she also makes the work available for people to be able to use with their clients as well like um but I love that she's a clinical psychologist i'm a clinical psychologist you're a clinical psychologist but we all do different things you know that speak to our individual passions and our callings it's so important isn't it we're not just cookie cutter clinical psychologists i 100 agree with that in fact you could argue i mean my of my caseload
去看看。我会发给你一个链接。她太棒了，她描绘客户经历的方式……所以她目前正在与儿童服务机构和寻求庇护者合作，她将这些融入到她的工作中，但她也让这些工作可供人们与他们的客户一起使用。但我喜欢她是临床心理学家，我是临床心理学家，你也是临床心理学家，但我们都做着不同的事情，你知道，这些事情诉说着我们个人的激情和使命。这太重要了，不是吗？我们不仅仅是千篇一律的临床心理学家。我100%同意这一点。事实上，你可以说，我的案例中
the bigger part of it is case management which i didn't know about um when i was training that's for sure and i think we can also lend our skills to not just psych sort of therapeutic um endeavors that there are other ways that we can use our skills. And I think that's the really exciting bit about being a psychologist in training now compared to back, you know, when I was doing it, it was a bit more sort of standardised, if you like. But now I think, you know, there's a bit more acceptance that there are lots of different ways to do psychology and they're all legitimate and um I think it's it means that you from the probably from training onwards you you get to think like that from the off um whereas I think I'm not sure that that was so strongly felt at
很大一部分是案例管理，我在接受培训时并不知道这一点，这是肯定的。而且我认为我们不仅可以把技能借给心理治疗方面的努力，还有其他方式可以运用我们的技能。我认为这正是现在作为一名心理学实习生最令人兴奋的地方，与我当时相比，那时稍微标准化了一些。但现在我认为，人们对心理学有很多不同的方式有了更多的接受度，它们都是合法的。而且我认为这意味着你从培训开始就可以那样思考，而我不太确定在
least certainly I didn't feel that particularly strongly when I was training um so yeah I'm kind of envious of trainees now in a way that you know if that's indeed how it is which I yeah it sounds like it might be yeah I think the pandemic has really exploded and advanced all of this hasn't it with the way that people are working and with their yeah like some some people have kind of myself included no longer work for the NHS at all um you know or or other organizations you know they might only be self-employed but many clinicians are doing a little bit of both you know a bit of employed work and a bit of a bit of their own work as well and it's I think encouraging us to use our psychology skills in ways that suit ourselves as well as the needs of our clients. And it's really empowering. Yeah, absolutely.
我接受培训时，这种感觉是否那么强烈。所以，是的，我有点羡慕现在的实习生，如果情况确实如此的话。是的，听起来可能是这样。我认为疫情确实爆发并推动了这一切，不是吗？人们的工作方式，以及他们……是的，有些人，包括我自己，根本不再为NHS工作了，或者其他组织，他们可能只是自雇，但许多临床医生两者都做一点，既有受雇的工作，也有自己的工作。我认为这鼓励我们以适合自己以及客户需求的方式运用我们的心理学技能。这真的很赋能。是的，绝对是。
In fact, I had a call earlier today with someone who was interested in working as an associate for us. And we we provide quite a lot of information up to the point of, you you know deciding if we're aligned in terms of our interest and um and one of her reflections was that it feels like not everyone can work in the field that you work in and i thought that's exactly why we produce all this information we don't want to waste anyone's time we certainly do not want to put our clients in a position where they're working with someone who then pulls out because it's not a good fit for them so in a way we are requiring our associates to kind of know themselves as well and know what their passions are know what their interests are and know that working certainly in our field with the systemic focus does require home visits for example it does
事实上，我今天早些时候和一个有兴趣作为我们的合伙人工作的人通了电话。我们提供了相当多的信息，直到决定我们在兴趣方面是否一致。她的一项反思是，感觉不是每个人都能在你工作的领域工作。我想，这正是我们制作所有这些信息的原因。我们不想浪费任何人的时间，我们绝对不想让我们的客户处于一种境地，即他们与一个因为不合适而退出的人一起工作。所以，在某种程度上，我们要求我们的合伙人了解自己，了解他们的激情所在，了解他们的兴趣所在，并知道在我们的领域工作，特别是具有系统性重点的工作，确实需要家访，例如，它确实
require um creative thinking training for care teams psychoeducation for the families, all of that stuff. And in a way that if you can explain it and justify it through your clinical formulation, pretty much if it makes sense and there is that motivation from the client themselves, the funding will probably be there to be able to kind of work through those challenges and those goals that have been identified, which is an incredible way to work. And like you, I'm not in the NHS anymore, but, and it's been a little while since I have been, but it's, it does feel like it's almost, you know, very different. Yeah, it's just very different to how we've been trained to work, I suppose. And so that creativity does need to be sort of on point in a way. But at the same time, you know, you can work in similar ways in the NHS, but just not for the length of time, I don't think. Certainly that's a feedback I've heard from associates and that I've experienced myself that it's not a sort of 12 sessions limitation due to
需要创造性思维、护理团队培训、家庭心理教育，所有这些东西。在某种程度上，如果你能通过你的临床构思来解释和证明它，只要它有意义，并且客户本人有那种动力，资金通常就会到位，能够解决那些已确定的挑战和目标，这是一种令人难以置信的工作方式。像你一样，我也不在NHS工作了，虽然我已经离开一段时间了，但它确实感觉非常不同。是的，这与我们受训的工作方式非常不同。所以这种创造力确实需要保持在水平线上。但与此同时，你可以在NHS中以类似的方式工作，只是时间长度不同，我不认为。这确实是我从合伙人那里听到的反馈，也是我自己经历过的，它不是那种由于
you know funding issues or just the way you know the system's set up it's it's so much more than that and if it's justifiable and it makes sense to the client and it ultimately as we often say with psychology prevents other problems from happening a bit later down the line it's worth front loading if you psychology support so that you prevent other things from happening a bit later down the line it's worth front loading if you psychology support so that you prevent other things from happening later on um and you get that stability which obviously our clients need and deserve yeah and anyone in all five whilst none of us are are you know can control or predict the future it's you know we have to be kind of entering into this work thinking that we can go the distance because I'm thinking that some of these cases
资金问题或系统设置方式而限制在12次会话。它远不止于此。如果它是合理的，对客户有意义，并且正如我们经常说的，心理学在稍后阶段防止了其他问题的发生，那么预先投入心理支持是值得的，这样你就可以防止以后发生其他事情。你获得了那种稳定性，这显然是我们的客户所需要和应得的。是的，虽然我们都无法控制或预测未来，但我们必须带着我们可以坚持到底的想法进入这项工作，因为我在想，其中一些案例
maybe even I don't know five years is it like you know how long is the longest case you could work with or could it be longer than that? Really good question so my longest standing case management client because it's a lifelong injury, as you say, and I started working with them as a paediatric when they were a child. I have been with them for the last 14 years and it doesn't look like we're going anywhere. So we're talking very long term. Psychology, our treating psychology work is a bit different but there are clients who because of the nature of their circumstances and the complexity around them easily a couple of years of different things you know working in different ways so yeah so for a case where you might be working with somebody with a legal team and case management
可能甚至，我不知道，五年？你工作过的最长案例有多久？或者可能更长？很好的问题。我工作时间最长的案例管理客户，因为这是终身伤害，正如你所说，我从他们还是孩子时就开始与他们合作。我已经陪伴他们14年了，看起来我们不会分开。所以我们谈论的是非常长期的。心理学，我们的治疗心理学工作有点不同，但有些客户因为他们的情况和周围的复杂性，很容易会有几年不同的工作方式。所以，是的，对于一个你可能与法律团队和案例管理一起工作
for for 10 years ultimately the goal would be that there'd be some sort of settlement and then the case management aspect would stop or or not what does that involve yeah I mean it really depends so it depends on things like what their experience was up to the point of settling, whether case management and the support they got was consistent and safe, felt safe for them. It might be it might depend on how well the evidence was collated up to the point of settlement, because, of course, post settlement, then the compensation will be whatever size it will be accordingly but obviously if there isn't any data and the engagement hasn't been there in order to get that data it might be that the compensation is a small award ultimately and that can't afford case management or other parts of the package and so there are big decisions to be made at the point of settlement. But often, if there is a case manager involved, an engagement is pretty decent from the client and the family.
10年的案例，最终的目标是达成某种和解，然后案例管理方面会停止吗？还是不会？这涉及什么？是的，这真的取决于情况。它取决于诸如他们在达成和解之前的经历，案例管理和他们得到的支持是否一致，是否让他们感到安全。它可能取决于在达成和解之前证据整理得有多好，因为当然，和解后，赔偿金将相应地确定。但显然，如果没有数据，也没有参与来获取这些数据，赔偿金可能只是一个小额裁决，无法负担案例管理或其他部分的费用。所以在和解时需要做出重大决定。但通常，如果有案例经理参与，客户和家庭的参与度相当不错。
And of course, the case manager is able to get the relevant data from other parts of the system, like the care teams and therapy teams, and can coordinate that well um more often than not the compensation will allow for the relationships to continue post settlement um and so because of the understanding that uh it's a lifelong um condition um um yeah that they will you know they would need the support for life okay so when you say data it's making me think about something I heard on the Jeremy Vine show the other day where it's saying that currently there's some health workers taking I think it's the government to to the high courts over long Covid but that's very tricky because they'd need to be able to prove without doubt that this had happened as a result of, they'd caught COVID as a result of their work, that they hadn't caught it elsewhere, for example. So when you're talking about data, that would be the data that they'd be having to produce, which is very tricky to do because, you know, because we just, you can't know that for sure.
当然，案例经理能够从系统的其他部分（如护理团队和治疗团队）获取相关数据，并能很好地协调这些数据。通常情况下，赔偿金将允许这些关系在和解后继续，因为人们理解这是一种终身状况，所以他们需要终身支持。好的，当你提到数据时，让我想起前几天我在Jeremy Vine节目中听到的事情，说是目前有一些卫生工作者因为长新冠问题正在起诉政府，但这非常棘手，因为他们需要能够毫无疑问地证明这是由于他们在工作中感染了新冠，而不是在其他地方感染的。所以当你谈论数据时，这就是他们必须产生的数据，这非常棘手，因为你无法确定。
You can say on the balance probability but for that sort of case you have to be certain so is that what you you mean by the data some stuff to back up your claim that it was it was someone else's responsibility rather than the the person um so when a case manager is, it's after the point of liability being assigned. So that bit that you're talking about is quite early on in the sort of pathway in the life cycle of a case manager's involvement. So once liability has been assigned to someone else causing the injuries. Money is then released in order to allow rehabilitation to commence because these cases can go on for years. Someone can't wait for rehabilitation for that long.
你可以说在概率平衡上，但对于那种案件，你必须确定。所以这就是你所说的数据吗？一些支持你主张这是别人的责任而不是当事人自己的责任的东西。所以当案例经理介入时，是在责任被分配之后。所以你谈论的那部分是在案例经理介入的生命周期的早期。所以一旦责任被分配给导致伤害的其他人。资金就会被释放，以便开始康复，因为这些案件可能会持续多年。某人不能等待康复那么久。
So some funds are released. And the idea is that those funds being released creates clinical data, outcome data. It produces evidence to demonstrate that the client actually needs that support. And so that's the data, I mean, that feeds back into the litigation strategy that then gets chewed over by the litigators and, of course, the defence solicitors to work out whether that's justifiable whether that's not justifiable whether that's been helpful whether it's not been helpful and that and that's partly why it goes the legal case can go on for so long because you need to
所以一些资金被释放了。其想法是，这些资金的释放产生了临床数据、结果数据。它产生了证据来证明客户确实需要这种支持。所以这就是我所说的数据，它反馈到诉讼策略中，然后由诉讼律师，当然还有辩护律师进行推敲，以确定这是否合理，是否不合理，是否有帮助，是否没有帮助。这部分原因就是为什么法律案件会持续这么久，因为你需要
work out over a period of time just how much is needed and obviously clients need to change people can start improving um and making positive changes others decline because of you know health conditions that ensue after their injury um so on and so forth complications and all sorts and so there needs to be a reasonable picture over a period of time as to what has been going on. Does that make sense? I'm with you, yes. So the data might be, for example, actually physiotherapy five times a week and speech and language therapy twice a week is keeping this client rehabilitating and to withdraw that would be detrimental to their well-being. So we need to make sure there's enough budget for that to continue. Absolutely and the experts that come in and get that snapshot picture of the client will have the
在一段时间内弄清楚到底需要多少。显然客户需要改变，人们可以开始改善，并做出积极的改变，其他人因为受伤后随之而来的健康状况而衰退，等等，并发症等等。所以需要有一段时间内关于正在发生什么事情的合理图景。这有道理吗？我明白了，是的。所以数据可能是，例如，实际上每周五次物理治疗和两次言语和语言治疗正在保持这位客户的康复，而撤回这些治疗将对他们的福祉有害。所以我们需要确保有足够的预算让这些继续下去。绝对是。而那些获得客户快照图景的专家将拥有
view of across their lifespan and so it needs to be scaled up for the x number of years that this person is expected to live and unfortunately unfortunately, in some cases, injuries can be life limiting. Okay, thank you so much for clearing that up for us and really clarifying and helping us paint that picture. Could you give us and our listeners your top tip for reducing burnout when you are an aspiring psychologist or mental health professional? Yeah think um so my top tips would be um whatever you do make sure that there's space for you in that um that offer um and I think it's very easy to get carried away with your passions with your interests for filling a gap in the market if you like um for you know with all that enthusiasm um it's very
跨越他们生命周期的视角，所以它需要为这个人预计生存的X年进行规模化。不幸的是，在某些情况下，伤害可能是限制生命的。好的，非常感谢你为我们澄清了这一点，并真正阐明并帮助我们描绘了那幅图景。你能给我们和我们的听众一个减少倦怠的秘诀吗，当你是一名有抱负的心理学家或心理健康专业人士时？是的，我想……所以我的秘诀是，无论你做什么，确保在那个提议中为你自己留出空间。而且我认为，很容易被你的激情、你的兴趣、如果你愿意的话，填补市场空白所冲昏头脑，带着所有的热情。
easy to get to a point of recognizing that actually i haven't built into this picture what i need in order to sustain all of that good stuff because the chances are if it's you know something you're doing it's probably going to be benefiting other people you don't want to do that for a short term you want to do it for the long term so build you know be okay about building yourself into um you know what that model is going to look like ultimately part-time working full-time working family commitments you know so on and so forth um and i would say related to that you don't have to do everything yourself um asking for help sort of delegating to specialists out there that can help you and i always use the example of a virtual assistant you know it's i mean they are a godsend frankly having someone who can assist you to do the things
很容易达到一个认识到“实际上，我没有把维持所有这些好东西所需要的东西纳入这幅图景”的地步。因为很有可能，如果这是你正在做的事情，它很可能会造福他人。你不想只做短期，你想做长期。所以，建立……对自己建立这种模式最终看起来会是什么样子感到自在。兼职工作、全职工作、家庭承诺等等。而且我会说，与此相关的是，你不必事必躬亲。寻求帮助，委派给外面的专家，他们可以帮助你。我总是用虚拟助理作为例子，你知道，坦率地说，他们是天赐之物。有一个人可以协助你做那些
that let's face it i'm no good at because I'm a psychologist I can do that but not so good at keeping my diary well you know that I thought we were meeting half an hour earlier than we actually were yeah people like me need a VA and I can spend a very long time focusing on things that get me stressed out number one and number two aren't going to get done well let's be honest and number three take away from the actual thing that i can do my specialism if you will and so outsourcing is okay it might cost but it's worth doing that cost benefit analysis in terms of what can i gain if i'm freed up for that hour yes i'm paying x amount for someone to help me with that
说实话我不擅长的事情，因为我是心理学家，我可以做那个，但不擅长管理我的日程。你知道，我以为我们比实际时间早半小时见面。是的，像我这样的人需要一个VA，我可以花很长时间专注于让我感到压力的事情，第一，第二，做得不好，让我们诚实地说，第三，分散了我真正能做的事情，我的专长。所以外包是可以的。它可能需要成本，但进行成本效益分析是值得的，如果我被解放出来一个小时，我能获得什么？是的，我支付X金额给某人来帮助我处理那个。
but that also means that i can think about doing something else and that something else might not even be you know a business something else it might just be I can go for that walk that I keep saying I want to go and do so those would be my two main sort of suggestions I think they're not sort of suggestions, I think. They're not sort of typical self-care and, you know, ideas that you would, you know, kind of, you know, not the go for a swim and, you know, go to the gym sort of ones. But I think for me, they've really helped ground me and helped me feel very sort of aware of what is important to me. But I think in, I suppose the, I suppose it could be a third thing,
但这同时也意味着我可以考虑做点别的事情，而那件别的事情甚至可能根本不是什么生意，它可能只是我可以去散散步，我一直说我想去散步。所以这些是我主要的两个建议，我想它们算不上什么典型的自我关怀建议，也不是那种你去游泳、去健身房之类的建议。但对我来说，它们确实帮助我脚踏实地，让我非常清楚什么对我来说是重要的。不过我想，或许还有第三点，
but it's kind of interlinked is just, you start then finding people who are like you when you know what your values are, you know, and you're giving time for yourself to be able to be expressed. And then you end up sort of connecting with people that you align with, and that's a really nice way to live life. I think good people, good balance and space to do whatever you need to do as well, because it's that oxygen mask on your face before you start helping other
但这与前两点是相互关联的，那就是当你清楚自己的价值观时，你就会开始找到和你志同道合的人，并且你有时间去表达自己。然后你最终会与那些与你契合的人建立联系，这是一种非常美好的生活方式。我认为优秀的人、良好的平衡以及做你需要做的事情的空间也很重要，因为这就像在帮助别人之前先给自己戴上氧气面罩一样，
people scenario, which I'm sure many people have said in your podcasts over the over it really matters doesn't it really really matters that's my version of it um i would say as it turns out i am also swimming a lot more than i used to which is really really great um and that helps with um you know with that side of things as well in terms of physical exercise and um well yeah that's yeah that side of things brilliant and if people want to know more about you and your case management or case management as a topic i know at one stage you had a podcast called the psychology of case management can people still listen to that yeah it's on the website um it's under our resources tab. Yeah, there's a whole load of information on there. There's
这是一个很多人在你的播客中都提到过的场景，这真的很重要，不是吗？真的非常重要。这就是我的版本。嗯，我想说的是，事实证明，我现在游泳的次数也比以前多多了，这真的非常棒。嗯，这在身体锻炼方面也对那方面有所帮助。嗯，是的，那方面确实很棒。如果人们想了解更多关于你和你的个案管理，或者个案管理这个话题，我知道你曾经有一个播客叫《个案管理的心理学》，人们现在还能收听吗？是的，它在网站上，在我们的资源标签下。是的，上面有大量的信息。有
various articles and fact sheets about working in the serious and catastrophic injury space. And with that psychological spin, of course, because that's our jam at the end of the day. But yeah, it's a it's a really great field to you know, if anyone's looking for, you know, sort of paid assistant work, case management is a really interesting field. Even if it's not psychology in the treating psychology sense, it's absolutely a field that you get to learn a lot about. Rehabilitation, brain injuries, spinal cord injuries, etc etc and systemic ultimately such important work and you are over on linkedin which is where i first connected to you your company is called psych
各种关于在严重和灾难性伤害领域工作的文章和情况说明书。当然，带有心理学的视角，因为归根结底那是我们的专长。但确实，这是一个非常棒的领域，如果有人在寻找带薪助理工作，个案管理是一个非常有趣的领域。即使它不是治疗心理学意义上的心理学，它也绝对是一个你可以学到很多东西的领域。康复、脑损伤、脊髓损伤等等，归根结底是非常重要的工作。你在领英上，我最初就是在那里和你建立联系的，你的公司叫Psych
works associates and on linkedin you are dr shabnam very calm with a hyphen aren't you so people can come and follow you there brill thank you i will make sure I link to all of that in the show notes. But thank you so much for helping illuminate me as well, but our watchers and our listeners about the work that you do as a case manager and for people with serious and catastrophic injuries. Keep doing what you do. Keep lighting up my LinkedIn as well. It's lovely to see you again. My pleasure.
Works Associates，在领英上你是Dr. Shabnam Very-Calm，带连字符的，对吧？所以人们可以去那里关注你。太棒了，谢谢你。我一定会确保在节目说明中链接到所有这些内容。非常感谢你帮助我以及我们的观众和听众了解你作为个案管理师为严重和灾难性伤害患者所做的工作。继续做你正在做的事情。继续点亮我的领英。很高兴再次见到你。我的荣幸。
Thank you so much and all the best to your audience. Oh, thank you. What an absolute pleasure it was to meet Shabnam and I hope that you will go and follow her over on LinkedIn. If you're on LinkedIn, and you certainly should be, come and follow me too. I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. What has this episode evoked for you? What's it made you think? Do come and let me know in the Aspiring Psychologist community free Facebook group. If you like this way of learning, thinking about novel and important concepts in psychology, including ethics, including formulation, including smashing interviews and application forms out of the park,
非常感谢，祝你的听众一切顺利。哦，谢谢。能见到Shabnam真是太荣幸了，我希望你们能去领英上关注她。如果你在领英上，而且你确实应该在，也来关注我吧。我到处都是Dr. Marianne Trent。这一集引发了你什么样的思考？它让你想到了什么？一定要来Aspiring Psychologist社区的免费Facebook群组告诉我。如果你喜欢这种学习方式，思考心理学中新颖且重要的概念，包括伦理、案例构思，以及在面试和申请表中脱颖而出，
do please consider coming along and joining the Aspiring Psychologist membership. Don't forget the books as well, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective and the Clinical Psychologist Collective too. And if you're looking at how you can work out how to get qualified therapist, check out Talking Heads. My pleasure to bring you this podcast. The next episode will be available from 10am on Saturdays on YouTube, and will be along from 6am as an MP3. Thank you for being part of my world. Take care. then let this be your guide with this podcast that you'll find you'll be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical
请务必考虑加入Aspiring Psychologist会员。也别忘了那些书，《Aspiring Psychologist Collective》和《Clinical Psychologist Collective》。如果你正在寻找如何成为合格治疗师的方法，请查看《Talking Heads》。很高兴为你带来这个播客。下一集将于周六上午10点在YouTube上发布，并于上午6点以MP3形式提供。感谢你成为我世界的一部分。保重。让这个播客成为你的指南，你会发现你正在通往合格的道路上，这是Dr. Marianne的《Aspiring Psychologist》。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《Clinical
Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become clinical psychologists psychologist it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Psychologist Collective》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。各种不同的途径让我感到惊讶，成为一名临床心理学家并没有完美的途径，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我做错了，也减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就放不下这本书了。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。